posée rue marbeuf nous nous retrouvons
tout de suite jean pierre chapel et bien
effectivement il vous ici la rue marbeuf
est en train de reprendre son calme
après la terrible explosion de ce matin
au loyer derrière moi on a commencé à
évacuer tout ce qui a pu être récupérées
notamment tous les débris de la voiture
piégée pour servir l'identification
connaître l'explosif qui a été utilisé
il y à aussi dans cette rue des tonnes
et des tonnes de verre de montceau de
morceaux de verre
c'est eux qui ont été les plus
meurtriers qui ont provoqué la plupart
des blessés car dans un rayon de 150
mètres il n'y a plus une seule vitre
intacte vous voyez les voitures qui ont
été touchés par l'explosion
et tout ceci donc maintenant est en
cours de déblaiement la rue est toujours
bloquée vient évidemment
revenons si vous le voulez bien sur les
événements de ce matin avec les images
de nos équipes sur pas arrivés sur place
que nous commente patrick bourrât
bien supérieure à celle de la rue
copernic le souffle et les éclats qui
ont jailli dans un rayon de 150 mètres
ont frappé de plein fouet les rares
passants présents ce matin à 9 heures
l'arrivée de ces primes
bien mais la plupart des blessés ont été
rapidement évacués vers les hôpitaux
la voiture piégée complètement
déchiqueté et toutes les voitures garées
rue marbeuf ont subi d'importants dégâts
le restaurant tunisien devant lequel
était garé la voiture piégée est
entièrement ravagé ainsi que les
appartements et les bureaux situés dans
l'immeuble juste au dessus
toutes les vitres dans un rayon de 300
mètres ont volé en éclats et la violence
de l'explosion a complètement dispersés
les débris du véhicule pire
c'est dans cet immeuble troisième étage
que se trouvent les locaux du journal
al-watan al-arabi qui aurait été visé
par cette attente et les équipes de
l'identité judiciaire s'efforce
maintenant de reconstituer le puzzle de
la voiture piégée qui devrait révéler la
nature de l'explosif utilisé mais
beaucoup se demande ici s'il y avait de
l'appétit de la penthrite dans cette
voiture
l'explosif également utilisé à copernic
et dans l'attentât du capitole
un témoin de l'explosion raconte wii ont
trouvé dans la boucherie donc vous étiez
me ferait à 10 mètres de l'endroit de
plus en plus qu'est ce que vous avez
ressenti une violente explosion qui a
duré environ deux à trois secondes
frei est très prolongée comme voilà les
pas du tout ponctué l'explosion très
violente en profondeur est aussi co dont
je suis sorti
on a vu une voiture pulvérisée avec le
pont qui a été éjecté jusqu'ici la
voiture d'un des employés qui a été
pulvérisée la mienne juste devant une
femme qui gisait juste à côté on la tire
et on l'a dépassée on l'a mise dans la
boutique il ya eu des flammes de
l'incendié
des plans très importante parce que
quand j'étais dans la quête on a vu
quelqu'un une flamme à aller je suis
jusqu'ici pratiquement il y avait
beaucoup de gens dans la rue à sont
heureusement rares heureusement
d'habitude à terre s'il ya beaucoup plus
de monde c'est par période mais c'est à
dire que le bac anciennes rames de métro
qui arrive je suppose
on a moins 50 personnes sur le trottoir
et puis là heureusement c'était dans une
période où il y avait qu une ou deux
personnes pour le trottoir alors le
bilan qui doit être définitif est de 46
et aidé à mort de 46 blessés dans les 46
blessés il y à a blessé très sérieux un
blessé très grave
dix blessés qui peuvent être considérés
comme sérieux et 35 blessés légers en
fin de matinée les ambulances évacuaient
encore les derniers blessés et bertrand
delanoë député socialiste de paris et le
maire de paris jacques chirac venait se
rendre compte peu après sur les lieux de
l'importance des dégâts causés par
l'explosion